[Applaudissements]
ces vidéos foisonnent sur le net toutes
plus dingue
ce lieu est un tube géant dans lequel
pulse une soufflerie c'est un simulateur
de vol en chute libre certains viennent
y chercher des sensations fortes pour
Géraldine c'est vital d'être là
voilà je parle d'une falaise je glisse
je me retrouve dans cette position là
si je panique je suis morte
donc
je teste des positions ou tout d'un coup
je me retrouve sur l'épaule et je dois
réussir à changer de position pour
pouvoir me retrouver à plat et sauver ma
vie quoi
dans la soufflerie les moteurs génèrent
un vent puissant il souffle jusqu'à 260
km heure
avec son moniteur elle enchaîne les
positions
l'objectif est de maîtriser son corps
face au vent comme lors d'un saut et
pouvoir faire le bon geste très vite
pour éviter une falaise ou un arbre
en fait elle apprend à piloter son corps
comme une machine volante
pour devenir cette championne Géraldine
ne laisse pas de chance au hasard
avant de sauter elle s'assure de tout
et la première chose c'est sa condition
physique
chaque jour elle court dans la montagne
pendant des heures
[Musique]
aujourd'hui elle escalade cette face car
elle veut repérer un nouveau lieu où
sauter et chaque fois c'est pareil des
heures de montée pour 3 minutes de
descente
[Musique]
elle ne se sépare jamais de son laser ce
petit appareil jaune qu'elle tient entre
ses mains
tu regardes la distance verticale exacte
avec la distance horizontale parce que
c'est un mur qui est pas totalement
vertical et je sais que avec la poussée
initiale de départ je peux faire 4 à 6
mètres et après à partir de 150 mètres
je peux aussi avoir beaucoup plus de
distance par rapport au mur
pour sauter il ne faut pas seulement un
corps bien fait mais aussi une tête bien
pleine
ça demande beaucoup beaucoup de
connaissances avant de pouvoir faire de
la wingsuit surtout sur des sauts
techniques comme comme je fais là mais
même ça demande beaucoup de
connaissances en vol ça demande d'être
super zen et c'est vrai que
que aujourd'hui ben il y a un peu une
explosion de la wingsuit et puis ouais
c'est super à la mode et puis voilà
aujourd'hui
alors que avant on était tout le temps
une communauté a volé tous ensemble et
ben aujourd'hui il y a des gens où je
sais que je veux pas aller voler avec
parce que j'ai juste pas envie d'être
témoins de
du vol de trop quoi parce que c'est des
gens qui me font peur le wingsuit n’est
encadré par aucune loi qui veut peut
sauter alors bien sûr il y a de très
nombreux accidents